[Música]
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros aquí en directo América son las
ocho y treinta de la noche en Bogotá no
siendo más esta introducción vamos con
los titulares de las noticias más
importantes de esta jornada
tras su reunión en la casa blanca con el
mandatario francés Manuel el presidente
Joe biden Se comprometió a ajustar la
ley de reducción de la inflación para no
perjudicar a empresas del sector verde
de Europa en este momento el jefe de
estado estadounidense ofrece una cena de
estado en honoramaco
en Ucrania las autoridades de gersón
denunciaron que la red eléctrica de la
ciudad está destruida a causa de los
incesantes bombardeos rusos contra
infraestructura crítica de esa urbe que
fue retomada de manos de Rusia el pasado
11 de noviembre las situaciones delicada
con el invierno a la vuelta de la
esquina
y hoy en el mundo se conmemora el Día
Mundial de la lucha contra el sida una
fecha que busca recordar la importancia
de las campañas de prevención y del
acceso a tratamientos y medicamentos
Naciones Unidas también resalta que es
fundamental que siga aumentando la
inversión para los avances en esta en
estos tratamientos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
iniciamos en la casa blanca Porque en
estos momentos se lleva a cabo la cena
de estado que el presidente Joe biden le
ofreció a su homólogo francés Manuel
maccom esto tras la reunión que ambos
líderes sostuvieron esta tarde en la que
vaiden se comprometió hacer cambios
técnicos a la ley de reducción de la
inflación conectamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez que se encuentra justamente en
la casa blanca Cristóbal Cuál es el
ambiente en este momento
pues excepción de todos los eventos que
han tenido lugar en esta segunda jornada
de visita de estado se cumplió con la
agenda con el horario establecido los
las parejas presidenciales se reunieron
pasadas las siete de la noche hora de
Washington para tomarse la foto oficial
antes de la cena que están teniendo en
este momento acá en la casa blanca llegó
con un vestido del diseñador Oscar de la
Renta Y pues la número de invitados es
bastante amplio pocos periodistas
lograron entrar ahí el full de
periodistas cercano a la casa blanca
tuvo acceso y ha descrito además pues la
vestimenta también de la la la la
primera dama de Francia también muy
elegante han descrito los periodistas
ya habíamos descrito que la música que
está en este momento tocándose desde
yang Batista pero hay que mencionar
también que
Manuel estuvo en el congreso antes de
llegar acá a la casa blanca a la cena de
estado bueno hice hemos dicho que lo más
destacado de la jornada fue justamente
el anuncio de biden sobre las
modificaciones a la ley de reducción de
la inflación Por qué preocupado a Europa
esta normativa
pues preocupa Europa porque hay empresas
que están vendiendoles semiconductores y
otros otros herramientas otros elementos
a Estados Unidos cuando Estados Unidos y
Joe biden pues decide sacar adelante
esta ley que subsidia a empresas
estadounidenses para producir sus
propios semiconductores su propia
tecnología pues Esto hace que la la
competitividad y la competencia de
empresas europeas en Estados Unidos pues
se vea amenazada precisamente dado los
subsidios que yo bailen Pues empieza a
darle a sus empresas estadounidenses no
solamente para crear mano de obra acá en
Estados Unidos sino también pues para
asegurar y dejar de depender de
potencias como yo baiden lo dijo sobre
todo de China no quiere seguir
dependiendo de China y quieren
fortalecer la mano de obra
estadounidense pues Cristóbal a usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación vamos
a estar muy pendientes de lo que falta
de Esta visita de estado del presidente
Emmanuel macron cambiamos de tema y
vamos a Ucrania porque las autoridades
de gersón denunciaron a través de
Telegram que la ciudad está sin red
eléctrica debido a los constantes
bombarderos rusos contra infraestructura
crítica los ucranianos aseguran que
Rusia quiere usar el frío como arma de
guerra en medio del Invierno que se
aproxima en el hemisferio norte Andrés
granadillo tiene los detalles
entre la oscuridad y el frío se
encuentran los habitantes de gersón tras
los ataques rusos sobre la
infraestructura eléctrica
aquí tiene lugar una grosera violación
del derecho internacional humanitario
lo más probable es que se trate de un
crimen de guerra con una alta
posibilidad se puede hablar de ataques
indiscriminados a infraestructuras
civiles a bloques de apartamentos
anoche nos desconectaron el gas el agua
y la electricidad de todo nuestras
puertas también fueron perforadas
según las autoridades un bombardeo
desconectó el suministro de la recién
restaurada electricidad muchos de los
residentes huyen de esta ciudad
ucraniana que hasta hace tres semanas
estuvo bajo dominio ruso
queremos irnos aquí ahora porque aquí da
mucho miedo iremos aquí y luego a
thernóbil allí esperaremos esperamos
volver pronto a casa
Así mismo
de 79 años decidió abandonar gerson y
unirse a sus hijos en kiev por el temor
a que la situación empeore además
recordó que nació y vive aún en guerra
el ataque fue tan masivo que nuestra
casa incluso empezó a temblar por eso
Tenemos que irnos esos bombardeos me dan
mucho miedo fui una niña de la guerra y
ahora soy una abuelita de la guerra
Ucrania aún no levanta cabeza tras los
constantes ataques rusos con drones y
artillería pesada sobre sus ciudades
siendo gersón la más fuertemente
afectada según la oficina presidencial
de Ucrania al menos dos civiles murieron
y otros resultaron heridos en todo el
país por los últimos bombardeos rusos
cada primero de diciembre se conmemora
el día internacional de lucha contra el
sida se trata de una fecha impulsada por
Naciones Unidas que busca crear
conciencia sobre la importancia de las
campañas de prevención y de acceso a
tratamientos además de la inversión en
investigación para la producción para
profundizar en esta jornada conectamos
con Jesús aways fundador de eights una
de las organizaciones más sólidas en
defensoría y acceso a tratamiento para
personas con VIH en Estados Unidos y
latinoamérica Bienvenido a France 24 qué
balance se puede hacer actualmente del
acceso a la prevención y tratamientos
contra esta enfermedad
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
el balance nos dice que que es
preocupante estamos con una lucha contra
la falta de de inversión
este año el informe de Naciones Unidas
nos dice cómo las desigualdades se ha
convertido en una amenaza para poder
alcanzar el fin del sida para el 2030
que es la meta de las Naciones Unidas
bueno y justamente algo que resalta la
ONU es la importancia de invertir
recursos en investigación para el avance
de los tratamientos en estos momentos se
puede hablar de que esa inversión es
suficiente
no la inversión es un reto los países
ricos están cada vez portando la la
inversión al VIH y en los recursos
financieros es un reto a nivel mundial
bueno y otro tema que genera una fuerte
polémica es que pese a que es una
enfermedad que se puede controlar para
evitar el contagio hay una hay aún una
gran estigmatización de los pacientes
Cuáles son los desafíos al respecto
sí en este momento una persona con VIH
en tratamiento que esté indetectable esa
persona no transmite el virus eso es
importantísimo entenderlo porque una
persona en ese con tratamiento
indetectable es el final de esa
infección no solamente puede estar
saludable ella misma asistitino no se lo
pasará a nadie así que es importantísimo
el acceso a diagnóstico que las personas
sepan su diagnóstico que puedan tener
acceso al medicamento y que pueda
mantenerse en tratamiento Ese es el gran
reto que tenemos en términos de
investigación es el el acceso a estas a
estos medicamentos bueno Y cuál se puede
considerar el principal avance que se ha
hecho desde que se descubrió la
enfermedad hasta este momento en materia
de tratamientos
Bueno hay un último tratamiento que
antirretroviral que inyección y se lo
pone cada dos meses eso es un avance
enorme ya que las personas que tienen
acceso a este medicamento se tiene que
poner solamente hacer inyecciones al año
y ya están bien pues señora usted muchas
gracias persona por compartirlo con
nosotros en France 24
Muchas gracias Hablamos ahora del
reciente informe que publicó amnistía
internacional en el que presentó pruebas
sobre 28 casos en los que funcionarios
de la policía de Colombia agredieron
sexualmente a manifestantes de las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2021
según el documento los hechos estuvieron
bajo un patrón generalizado que
pretendía castigar a los manifestantes
veamos más detalles en el informe de
Juan Pablo lucumí
[Música]
al menos 28 personas sufrieron
agresiones sexuales a manos de policías
durante el paro nacional de 2021 en
Colombia según el informe de amnistía
internacional se trató de un patrón
generalizado de violencia Estatal las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos tuvieron
lugar principalmente en dos situaciones
durante la actuación de la Policía
Nacional para dispersar las protestas y
durante las detenciones que siguieron a
la intervención inicial en ambas
situaciones actuando a título oficial
hubo agentes de la Policía Nacional que
cometieron actos que iban desde los
insultos sexistas y las amenazas hasta
la violencia sexual la organización
describió específicamente los 28 casos
de las cientos de denuncias recibidas el
informe de 68 páginas presenta el
contexto de violencia previo a las
protestas que vivía al país así como los
casos de impunidad y las limitaciones
para la atención y garantía de acceso a
la justicia
in relation no ha habido ni una sola
condena en relación con las múltiples
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidos durante estas protestas y ni
una sola condena penal en relación con
la violencia sexual el gobierno debe
reconocer lo que sucedió públicamente
con firmeza debe disculparse por lo que
se hizo con los cuerpos de jóvenes con
la mujer y la juventud y con los
afrocolombianos
según amnistía internacional los abusos
de índole sexual tuvieron lugar entre el
28 de abril y el 30 de junio de 2021
cuando miles de colombianos salieron a
las calles para rechazar la gestión del
gobierno del entonces presidente Iván
Duque vamos ahora a Francia porque se
iniciaron los alegatos de las partes en
el proceso por el accidente del avión
que en 2009 sufrió una el accidente que
sufrió una aeronave de Air France que
viajaba entre Río y París y que dejó 228
fallecidos los abogados de las víctimas
tratan de desarmar la defensa del
constructor eiras y de la compañía los
dos están acusados por homicidio
involuntario en este juicio Erika
olavarría nos amplía la información
desde la capital francesa
los abogados de las casi quinientas
partes civiles en este proceso
comenzaron hoy sus alegatos ellos
coinciden primero en manifestar su
preocupación por la tardanza que tuvo
este proceso que se volvió además muy
técnico en algunas ocasiones Y que
muchas veces corrió Incluso en el año
2019 el riesgo de ser anulado están
tratando ellos de poner humanidad de
poner sentimiento como decía un juicio
que debido al hecho de que es un
accidente aéreo se volvió a veces muy
técnico también demostraron su
preocupación o su enojo con el armador
europeo airbus porque la compañía en
todo momento ha inculpado a la
tripulación de este vuelo sin embargo
Ellos dicen que el bus conocía muy bien
el problema que tenían las ondas pitot
que son aquellas que fallaron y
provocaron este accidente sin embargo
Aunque había habido varios incidentes
una veintena lo hicieron nada por
cambiarlas y finalmente también los
abogados de la parte civil se quejaron
nuevamente en contra de
la compañía por no haber preparado
suficientemente a la tripulación para
hacer frente a una crisis como la que
tuvieron esa noche en la cabina los dos
copilotos y el comandante del avión las
dos compañías que en un primer momento
aparecían enfrentadas Cuando comenzó
este juicio finalmente parecen alinearse
en una misma posición se conocen ya hace
50 años por lo tanto no tienen interés
de enfrentarse dicen los especialistas
el bus insiste en que la culpa es de la
tripulación y el France aunque no ataca
directamente a quienes trabajaban para
la compañía los dos copilotos y el
comandante Sí dice que no entiende por
qué procedieron como lo hicieron y que
por lo tanto no puede manifestarse y
vamos a finalizar en Nueva York porque
inicio la temporada navideña una época
en la que los grandes almacenes muestran
su creatividad en las vitrinas el
minorista de lujo Bird Goodman celebra
la temporada con el mensaje magia en
proceso
presenta ventanas interactivas osos
vestidos con suéteres de Punto y zorros
vestidos con cuadros escoceses y
blooming days brilla con bolas disco
maniquíes patinadores sobre hielo y una
colorida pantalla de video
[Música]
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que ya llega marinas ardiña con
toda la información en Expreso de
oriente feliz noche para todos
[Música]